hi this is preshtalwalker can you figure
out this problem which is driving people
crazy
your job is to put numbers in each of
the four boxes to make all of the
equations true
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
this problem is actually a system of
linear equations
we're actually going to manipulate the
equations and prove there is no possible
solution for this problem
the first horizontal equation says that
blue minus red is equal to nine
the second vertical equation says red
plus green is equal to two
we can add up these two equations
to conclude that blue plus green is
equal to 11.
we can then look at the first vertical
equation to say blue plus yellow is
equal to 12
and we can look at the second horizontal
equation
to get negative yellow plus green is
equal to negative fourteen i've
multiplied the second equation by
negative one
this is so that we can cancel out the
yellow variable
and then we get the result blue plus
green is equal to negative two
now if you focus on the two results we
have we have something that's
contradictory in one case we have blue
plus green is equal to 11. in another
equation we found blue plus green is
equal to negative 2.
it's not possible for these both to be
true at the same time
therefore we've reached a contradiction
and therefore this is impossible and
there is no solution to this equation to
the system of equations
now you might ask yourself is it just
because we have the numbers 9 14 12 and
2
is it possible that this system of
equations could have another solution if
we put different numbers
so if the first equation was equal to b1
if the second horizontal equation was b2
the first vertical equation was b3 and
if the second vertical equation was b4
is it possible could we actually figure
out a solution
this is the type of problem that you
would deal with in linear algebra
the result would be a vector of four
variables b1 b2 b3 and b4 and these are
constants which are known
this is going to be the result of four
equations
four variables which is blue red yellow
and green we can represent the system of
equations by a linear operator which we
can write as the following matrix
if we multiply the matrix by the vector
of variables we end up with the results
so the first line of the matrix says
blue minus red is equal to b1
the second line of the matrix says
yellow minus green is equal to b2 the
third line says blue plus yellow is
equal to b3 and the fourth line says red
plus green is equal to b4
and that represents the four equations
that we have on the left hand side
now we can solve this system of
equations if we invert the matrix we'll
then get a unique solution by
multiplying
the vector of b1 to b4 by the inverted
matrix
however you can only invert a matrix if
its determinant is not zero
this matrix has a determinant that's
equal to zero so we cannot find a unique
solution for these four variables
because the matrix has a determinant
equal to zero there are two possible
things that can happen
one is you might have no solutions which
is what we had in this video
another thing you could have is you
might have a system of equations that's
underspecified
you would have infinitely many solutions
if you had the equations x plus y equals
2 and 2x plus y equals four you can see
that the second equation is two times
the first equation you don't get any new
information and therefore it's like
putting a line right on top of itself
there are infinitely many solutions
so no matter how you try
and solve this system of equations
you're either going to end up with no
solutions or infinitely many solutions
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker if you like this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description